ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show what a week it's been
you can't even get a good scam going in
this country anymore and it's not even a
scam
ironically what's being what's happening
if you followed
anything uh is that uh you know
people uh are trying to buy stock
in a free market um and they're trying
to buy companies like gamestop and amc
and nokia these are not companies that
are under investigation
and um they have pushed the prices of
these stocks up
forcing all the hedge fund managers and
hedge funds that have shorted these
stocks
to cover their bets and they're not
happy about it
so it's it's it's really these
independent day traders
versus you know the goliath uh
institutional big banks hedge fund
people
and it's been it's been unfolding for
the last few days one of the most
interesting things in finance
that has probably ever happened in
history and people are lining up on
either side of it dave portnoy
uh when elon musk seemed to be for this
kind of
you know um disruption and then you have
people like elizabeth warren who's a
fraud
which we know saying things like
casino-like swings and stock prices of
gamestop reflect
wild levels of speculation that don't
help game stops
workers or customers and could lead to
market instability
what a word market instability
today i told the sec to explain what
it's exactly doing to prevent market
manipulation so if you had
any illusion that people like elizabeth
warren wanted you to make any money
you now that illusion has been smashed
permanently
they don't want you to make any money
they don't care
they want they may want you vaccinated
but they don't want you to have
any [ __ ] money okay elizabeth warren
does not want you to have money
to better your life and the life of your
family okay
remember everyone who is against this
remember everybody that came out
and said that this was egregious and it
leads to market instability
and it's uh what it really is is people
trying to wrestle back
a little bit of power not even a lot a
tiny bit of power
from these oligarchs and they won't have
it they can't do it
they won't let you do it gamestop gets
to 400 they halt trading
right yeah they halt it robin hood app
the guy stopped selling uh
amc they stopped selling gamestop and
i'm in amc a little heavy and uh
you know i didn't get into gamestop
early enough um
but this is uh the biggest disruption
the market seen in a very long time
and and people like elizabeth warren are
coming out and going we know what's best
for you
and what's best for you is that you make
the money that we say you make
we're fighting to get you another dollar
an hour at your
shitty slave wage job don't worry about
it
we're trying to get you that and we
might get you a little fake health
insurance too we might get your pretend
insurance
how about that you'll sleep easier with
pretending shirts
but don't ever think you can get into
the game with the big boys because they
own us
it's it's absurd and uh
i of course um have no illusions about
uh i unfortunately i think people should
hold these stocks if you can
push hold their feet to the fire keep
doing that
um and we're just going to keep seeing
this they're going to make it harder and
harder
they'll introduce some new regulation
they'll say there's a certain net worth
requirement
to trade probably they're going to play
around with all these things i mean you
have hedge fund managers crying on cnbc
leon cooperman's in tears on cnbc be
like i care
i care that's why i'm upset it's because
i care
do you care leon cooperman
um but yeah i mean and they keep
bringing him on he's like freaking out
yeah he's always freaking out he's
freaking out
this will end badly for who
by the way it's been ending badly for
the american people
every day for the last [ __ ] 40 years
now it might end badly for you and your
friends
they don't want you in the hamptons
folks they don't want you at their
country club
and then he goes well i voted for biden
i voted my values over my pocketbook
i just want to make sure everybody knows
that i voted for biden you know
um it is really interesting to watch
this all unfold
and these guys are coming out
and they're crying
i mean they're they're tearing up at the
idea of this
at the thought of people exercising the
freedom
to buy securities on an app like
robinhood is making these people cry
because they care about you remember
that
they're they're you're making money and
they're crying
because they care about you
it would be like if you walked in with a
winning
scratch off and you won 30 grand
and everyone you told started crying
you're going this isn't the way it
should work
this what about the fundamentals what
well what about necessary market
functions
what they manipulate prices all the time
they inflate things
they short they do everything okay they
care nothing about rules laws
all they care about is winning and
having more money than you
so when you start to [ __ ] up their money
they get on cnbc and
cry and say that this is bad for the
system it's not gonna end
badly uh and just be honest about it
tell people why it's not gonna end badly
tell people why it's gonna end real bad
just look at cnbc look at the host of
cnbc go
we'll do another 911. straight up tell
them they go we're prepared to go to
full we'll release more pandemics we're
working with somebody right now and
we're going to do another we're going to
do a
real coronavirus soon it's going to be
bad not that this one's not real but
they're like we're gonna do
the plague the next thing we're gonna
try is to plague
i'm on clubhouse now which is a new app
that uh i have invites to and none of
you are getting invites
uh clubhouse is an invite-only app it's
drop-in audio chat
it's a social network that's based on
your voice where people around the world
come to network talk to each other
have open conversations about the issues
of the day
and i was sponsored by michael gruen who
is a
uh bitcoin guy also he owns the uh
sway house which is a tick-tock house in
los
angeles and he's a very funny guy who uh
is very successful entrepreneur and he
brought me on
and everybody on there not everybody but
a lot of people on there are
entrepreneurs
venture capitalists investors
people that uh have come up with very
successful apps
really really successful people in the
tech space
and a lot of the rooms are very fun we
goof around they bring me on i'm like
you know they invite me as a speaker i'm
a comedian i throw in a funny line
every few minutes but reality i listen i
listen
and some of the conversations are very
interesting and informative and some of
them are terrifying
because you're meeting your captors
truly you're
you're getting into a they're running
the world
they're going to run the world they're
going to win when they talk they have
this very cold
blooded like you know some of them say
well you know we have to put guard rails
up online
don't we and you're like god they're
going to win it's terrifying but they're
going to win
but it really is for a guy like me i'm
listening to my cat
it would be like if there was an app in
the 1800s where
slaves could ask questions to their
masters
so you're shackled in a barn and you get
to go on an app and go
what do we think tomorrow is it field
tomorrow and they go
well production has been very low and we
do blame the weather but a lot of that
is because we feel that the manpower is
lacking so we are going to get in the
field tomorrow
and then we're going to try to
streamline that we're going to really
try to cover all of our bases i think
what's really important is that we build
an infrastructure
and then you're sitting there as a slave
and yeah that sounds good and one day
i'll be a master
i'm going to own a plantation one day
and i'll shackle people up in a barn
and tell them what they can and can't
say and how they can say it it is a
little terrifying on there and it's fun
and it's funny but when you hear these
people talk
um they love the penta i mean they
they're they're gushing one guy goes
there's gonna be a pandemic now every
five years
it's just the way the world is now it's
just the way the world is
everyone's gonna have to wear masks
forever we were sharing way too many
germs before
everybody stay in your house stay online
and use our app use our app the world is
now different
and all the things that can make the
world livable
coincidentally are all the things we've
invested in
isn't that nice don't go outside there's
new strains every day is another strain
the andromeda strain
they're all coming from brazil from
africa yeah it's coming
they're all coming the strains won't end
and then these people on this app are
talking about the new world that
everyone will live in which will be
digital forever
it is the dystopian nightmare that you
feared they are preparing it for you
as you sleep truly they are and not to
sound too crazy about it
but when you hear these people talk and
they're they're not emotional
it's very cold it's calculated they're
just like this is how it is now
we're living in the world of pandemics
we're going to get one all the time
they're going to be here and in order to
live with this new world we're going to
have to distance
we're going to have to use this our
infrastructure that we've built
this is what you have to use you have to
be online all the time using our apps
to make a living to do anything and by
the way
if you get a little wacky we're gonna
delete you delete and where are you
gonna go
there's nowhere for you to go there's
nowhere for you to go because you're
gonna get another strain
don't walk into an office the strains
coming as that's the strain from
pakistan
it's the pakistani strain so you have no
other option
you know create your own twitter people
went on parlor they said ab [ __ ] that
well you can make money in the market if
you want buy stocks
ah [ __ ] that we'll turn that off
and pretty soon and it's already
happening it's like
you know we'll just start deleting you
your ability to to earn a living
if we so choose this is enforced
compliance
and the guys that are on the other side
of that guy's like eric weinstein who's
on clubhouse all the time he's a
really brilliant guy he talks you know
19 20 hours a day on clubhouse every day
and it's still not enough you know it's
like tulsi gabbard was in a room with
him and somebody would ask her a
question and he'd
they'd be like tulsi what's it like
running a presidential campaign
weinstein jumps in he's like
here's what tulsi learned you're like
wait what but
he's he is an ally right eric weinstein
actually doesn't want this and you hope
that he wins but i don't know if he will
because the other side seems to be very
uh competent and they seem to be
and this is just listening on this app
which i spent three or four hours on a
night
because it's [ __ ] fascinating i do a
little joke every now and then everybody
goes oh tim's a comedian
isn't that funny uh but they i'm a roach
in there they look at me like a
i'm like a jester that they bring out
like hey make everyone laugh and then
we're gonna talk about uh you know the
type of shackles that we get that's
gonna go right around the arm
yeah we got a good one we're saving
money on metal so the chain the chain
we're switching from metal we're gonna
do an elastic chain it's like a polymer
so you feel like you can go somewhere
but it snaps you back
so and that's what they talk about and
then every now and then i come in and i
make a joke and i'm like
you know i'm like well what around my
polymer chain and they go
but it to to listen to them it's it's
it's a little
uh disturbing it's a little disturbing
how
intuit they are in terms of like
you know this pandemic there's no end in
sight and never will be
there's never going to be and again it's
not this like
vast conspiracy this is how these
[ __ ] make their money
this is how they're gonna make their
money and they're gonna pretend that
they're the greatest people that have
ever lived
and they've ushered humanity into this
new era of not being able to leave your
home or speak
and it's for your own good they're
crying on cnbc
because they're worried about you
because they care about you
you're not going to be able to speak or
buy stocks or leave your house
because they care don't ever forget that
this
is wrapped up in altruism in a way that
like nothing ever
finance guys are like cuddly care bears
compared to the tech people finance guys
are like yeah we're here to rob you
they're they're clumsy they're idiots
this fat [ __ ] on cnbc's crying
he's clearly a goon you can identify him
and go goon
they wear pinstripe suits i mean they
might as well be the monopoly guy you
could see them coming a mile away
these finance guys or even though
they're in their jeans now these hedge
fund douchebags
with their [ __ ] aviators you still
can see them and know
but the tech people really are utopians
they are creating a new world and they
just might let you live in it
they just might let you live in that
world
for a little bit until you get visibly
upset
you know and that's when they're gonna
have to get you out of there
that's where they're gonna have to open
the trap door and you're
done and you hear that when somebody
said to me this was a big
big person who said we need to put guard
rails up online
i get a little heart flutter a little
palpitation i'm like what do you mean by
that
and then later on a guy comes in and
goes listen we're gonna have another
pandemic every five years
so we're never gonna be able to go back
to living the way we used to live we
shared way too many germs
work is gonna be exclusively from home
you're gonna have to use these uh
applications
this is the way we're gonna do things
now this is the wave of the future
friends are gone unless they're digital
i mean it's really wild
uh to to hit you know the vaccines are
coming
uh and some of them we need without a
doubt
but they're coming there'll be 12 of
them you won't know which one to get
everyone there'll be different vaccines
different vaccine for every season it'll
be like fashion week
with needles what's the spring line look
like
you know are you getting a summer
vaccine what's to some you know
gucci will start making them soon
they'll have vaccines from everybody
and and that's it and public health
policy
and and tech policy is all going to be
fused together
and it's all going to be to help you
it's going to be it's all going to be
for you
that's all and there's going to be a
cartel of companies that you have to do
business with to exist on this planet
and if you choose not to and i remember
when like you know i would talk to
people and this was
years ago and we've even talked to them
on the show where they'd go no what's
coming is fully autonomous
cities where everything is delivered to
you via drone you you don't really need
to leave if you leave there's like a
park you can go to
uh that'll be monitored there'll be
cameras everywhere you're gonna be
listened to
uh the alexa will just be the beginning
every single uh appliance in your house
will be a smart appliance to listen to
everything you say
they'll they'll use that information to
market things to you which will be
delivered by drone
and then if you go on let you know
there'll be social credit scores similar
to china
uh are you a team player or are you
disgruntled are you anti-social
and what the line of that is just
because they're going to keep moving it
so you keep moving the line of is of
what's considered anti-social
what's considered a problem and it's
just
it'll stifle all art which is already
dead
let's be very honest there's there's
very few things out there that you go
god is that
good god was that good it's gonna be
what you see now tick tock people
dancing
you know buy the merch i'm gonna dance
in a stairwell
in a mansion and that's it that's what
you're gonna get you'll get movies
that are a little more than spawn con
you're gonna just get spon con
you know so yeah it'll be vaccine spon
con
you'll just watch your favorite avenger
get vaccinated
even the hulk needs a shot don't worry
it's coming
folks being on this app for three
[ __ ] days
it's coming tomorrow it's not coming in
six months or a year
it's here you just don't know it yet i'm
telling you right now
if you sell your stuff online you're
definitely in the right business most
people are shopping online because there
are new strains every day have you heard
that means a lot of orders coming in and
a lot of voters you'll need to ship out
fast that's why online sellers like you
need
ship station no matter how much you sell
ship station makes it super easy to
manage
and ship all your orders from your sales
channels faster cheaper
and more efficiently you can import
orders from any sales channel
ship with any carrier access discounted
shipping rates automate just about any
shipping task
you'll spend a lot less time on shipping
and a lot more time on growing your
business the things you need to do
marketing you know all this stuff that
you need to do as a successful business
you know you're not making any money in
the market right now so you might as
well start selling your [ __ ]
no matter what you're selling amazon
etsy your own app website ship station
funnels all your orders in a one simple
interface
that you can manage from anywhere even
your cell phone
you'll even get access to amazing
discounts with major carriers ups fedex
usps
easily compare carriers and ship the
best solution every time
with ship stations small businesses can
access the same rates usually reserved
for a fortune 500 company
it's so important if you're if you're an
online retailer to do this stuff
this is essential if you're a small
business and by the way you get two
months free
ti mdi llon 60 day free trial two months
free
stress free shipping no hassle that's 60
days if you're a starting
business small business you need 60 days
free
and that's important and you don't have
to worry about anything other than
making your business the best it can be
so again you go to shipstation.com
s-h-i-p-s-t-a-t-i-o-n shipstation.com
code t-i-m-d-i-l-l-o-n 60-day
free trial i can't say enough about
sheath
underwear everybody loves it
everyone that has it loves it it's
nice they have a flexible pillowcase for
your junk
it's literally all i wear now they are
the best
you have to try it yourself give them a
google do some research
on the inventor robert patron
is he a patron robert patron check the
story it's interesting
and even somewhat inspiring this is the
guy who was
in the military that's right and he
served our country yes
you know it's pretty damn cool
when you have somebody who
is a veteran who then gets into another
business yeah
and i don't care i mean listen i'm not
going to start relitigating everything
that might happen over there
what is a civilian really what what does
a civilian mean
isn't anyone a threat i'm not gonna ask
why you got out of the military
i'm not gonna ask how we got out of the
military it's uh it's uh who cares
i start going nuts i'm not gonna ask you
some of the things he did
were leaked out by edward snowden i'm
not going to get into that doesn't
matter
he served the country and now he makes
underwear and
the underwear is good so it does not
matter
you know what what whatever happened
whatever he was involved in
doesn't matter i don't need to i'm not a
perfect person are you a perfect person
no no
no that's all that's all i'm saying i'm
sure this guy did everything on the up
and up
you know you're throwing a couple of
beers with the down with the guys from
blackwater
maybe you're going to the town you raise
a little hell maybe you raise a little
hell over there
i'm not i'm not i'm not a rat
i'm not somebody who's gonna you know i
don't know what happened
doesn't matter move on
as he clearly has it's great
here we go me ranting about my thoughts
and feelings point
is that i love this underwear and they
pay me to promote them but they could
have left after my last ad read
because because they didn't because it
was funny right because that's
here's the reality they don't mind what
i say right
that's what we like they're fans of
comedy support them because of that
you know what i mean who cares
that it may or may not be run by a
genocidal maniac
like colonel kurtz from apocalypse now
doesn't matter
doesn't matter women in chip women and
children
they can carry bombs like everyone else
do you get that a toddler
can be as devastating as a as a
as a a regular man so they gotta go
that's all that's what i'm trying to say
this guy
served his country
did he lock chelsea manning in a cell
maybe
but it's not my business what he did
because she's a rat she ratted
he had a couple of beers they took guns
and they just fired into a crowd to just
keep people on their toes
she's underwear dot com
sheath s-h-e-a-t-h
dot c-o-m sheath underwear dot com
use code tim to save 20 percent
you use the code tim you save 20
everything you see now is so insane
pregnant people not pregnant women
pregnant people
tweet a man can't get pregnant you'll
lose your account you will lose
your account you're a turf
you're a biological essentialist i'm
telling you right now
this disease has gotten to the brain
it's spread it's like a doctor sitting
down and going
the disease has spread there's not going
to be any let up
really and i was like so
taken back by how cold and calculated
um a lot of these people are in these
apps and how they really
truly believe that they're doing the
right thing for you
they truly believe that they actually
believe it
it's not like a bunch of wall street
guys in the room going hey we're getting
over
it's true believers it's a cult and they
believe that the world should look a
certain way
and if you fit into that you fit into
that and if you do not fit into that you
are going away
you're gonna go away and
you know i mean this these articles come
out we've talked about it with whitney
webb but you know where they go listen
you're gonna own nothing you're gonna be
happy you're not gonna own a car
you won't own a house good luck you
might not own stock you're not gonna own
a business
you won't own your own body soon because
he'll tell you what has to go into that
what's allowed what's not allowed
um and this is the future and i've never
been more convinced of it than spending
time on that
and the app is fun it's fun
hearing how it's gonna happen isn't that
sick
it's actually fun hearing how they're
gonna get ya
it's amusing it's better than tv
stop watching ozark listen to your
captors
they're telling you they are telling you
you don't
need the next season but to marty and
wendy figure out
who cares these people are telling you
how they're going to shackle you to a
floorboard
listen to them i'm telling you don't
make the mistake
don't make the mistake of ignoring them
when they talk don't
ignore what is going to be the future of
your life
and your children's life i wish it
wasn't fun
because it is fun going huh that's a
good idea
how are you going to remove
all my freedom little by little and i'll
thank you for it
i'll thank thank you thank you for this
that's what they want elizabeth warren
wants you to thank her for telling you
you can't make any money
she wants you to come and say thank you
for protecting me from
prosperity thank you for protecting me
from earning a dollar
thank god i was about to earn forty
thousand dollars
and maybe paid down some student debt
and help my mother out
thank christ you got in the way of that
i mean that's truly where we're at now
as a country
but that clubhouse that man it's a lot
of fun except our friend keeps ruining
it
we have this friend alex who keeps
rooting and he jumps into every room
you got to get invited to these rooms
and i want new friends i want to be
friends with the captors
i want to be friends with them these
some of these people are so young
they're in their early 20s
they started a hedge fund at like four
years old very wealthy yeah the
instagram
picture is like them tongue kissing joe
biden these people are connected
i want those they're i want to be
friends with them
i want to be friends with the captors
so every now and then they could they
could let me out of the cage
and i'll do a dance and then they bring
me right back in and i go
can i can i stay on the property tonight
they go not tonight
back in the cage but we really enjoyed
the show and i go okay
thank you cause you'll say thank you
thank you and then go please vaccinate
tim on the way back so he forgets
everything that happened
but i'm trying to make friends and then
alex
keeps ruining it by jumping in and not
shutting his goddamn mouth
shut your mouth alex i'm known a little
bit on this thing i'm a comedian so like
sometimes they let me in the rooms and
they wouldn't know who i am some of them
know who i am because i've done rogue in
a bunch they're all like we want rogan
to be on clubhouse i spoke to him he
said i'm busy mom [ __ ] that mom
yeah you're never gonna get he's never
gonna be on clubhouse dummy
but like we're talking to tulsi on there
and we're talking eric weinstein it's a
lot of fun
it's the future
and it's fun but some of those rooms in
there you're like
whoo it's gonna get
interesting going forward it will but
i wish we didn't have someone ruining it
all the time
as a side note my aunt is not thrilled
uh with the direction of the show
i don't know why but i've heard that
from several family members
she's not thrilled with the direction
we've gone in i don't know
i don't know what upset her did she not
like the ads
i don't get it we're also moving to
austin texas
yes i don't know if we've said that
we're leaving we're gone
we're done we tried we gave it we gave
it the old college try
you know yeah i mean i haven't i didn't
go to college but i gave it a try
and everyone i know every smart person i
know every big
uh youtuber i talk to them and a lot of
them
are out a lot of them are leaving uh
you know pick the reason there's 25. we
wanted to stay here to collaborate with
people yes
they're not going to be here costs a lot
of money to live in the state cost of
living is high
tax burden is high there's less and less
to do
you know what are we gonna do gotta go
gotta go
and now hearing being in clubhouse for
future i'm like oh yeah
i don't know i i could wake up tomorrow
and have no career i could wake up
tomorrow and just you know
log on to everything and be like he's
done they might do it after this
they might be like we let him in and
then he's [ __ ] that mother fat
fat [ __ ] he said some things
so i don't know but being in a career
like the one that i have
and knowing what's coming down the pike
makes me want to
go down to a state where i can live
simpler less expensive rock out as much
as i can
make a lot of funny videos make a lot of
uh
do a lot of fun podcasts go out and do
live shows maybe make longer form stuff
and uh you know until uh you know they
turn the lights out
we don't know when they're gonna turn
the lights out but they're gonna turn
the lights out you know
and i don't know when it's going to be
i'm hoping it's in five years i hope i
get a little run and then maybe we'll
have live we'll be able to do live you
you'll have to come see us
live and if you have 12 vaccinations
you'll be able to sit in a room and then
hear people speak i don't know what's
going to happen
but i mean eventually everything will be
a pejorative that can get you thrown
offline i mean if you call someone fat
they'll go bullying out
what that's what's gonna happen no
matter what you say
call someone a woman misgender someone
by mistake
out what's amazing about these tech
people is they're all very rich
and they're all they're all very
invested in the idea
that they're the good guys so in order
to be the good guy when you're making
all of the money in a society with a lot
of inequality and i'm not even i'm not a
marxist i'm not saying that
you shouldn't be able to make money but
i'm saying the cognitive dissonance you
have to have
to make a billion dollars and then have
your head hit the pill and go
i'm the good person here like i'm part
i'm a force for good
in order to be a force for good you have
to clean up everything else around you
which is are people being mean don't be
mean
yes i have a billion dollars and you
don't have shoes but don't be mean
that's what it is so they're basically
like we're the
we're the homeowner we're a task force
it's like if the whole monitor of your
school
showed up in a bentley and
walked into school with gold teeth and a
chain
and stood in the hall and and and your
school was like a school that was
falling apart
and nobody and the teachers had to spend
money uh
on school supplies because they didn't
get support from the administration and
after my little rant about teachers
thank you for the dms
uh but it's like that type of school and
the kids are on a school lunch program
and everyone's broke and busted
and shot and your whole monitor shows up
in a rolls royce
and just gets out and like you and your
buddy
are teasing each other walking down the
hall
you know maybe you and him maybe he's
chinese
and and you're uh black and you're
you're making fun of each other
okay because that's what people do they
make fun of each other and kids
aren't good comedians they're not me so
they do
base level comedy you know and also by
the way
if you continue to do that comedy you
can make 100 million dollars so
uh they do base level comedy you're
black you're asian whatever and they say
it you know
and then the whole monitor goes what the
[ __ ] did you say
i go dude it's my friend we're going to
class and she's like the [ __ ] you are
going to class
and then you go hey not for nothing but
you've got a rolls royce
and you've got gold teeth and like we're
[ __ ] here the school barely
exists the teachers are overworked
nobody has any goddamn money
we can't even afford books our parents
are on opioids
can you let us kid around from class to
class which we don't even [ __ ] learn
anything in any way
can you let us kid around in the hall no
and then she he or they
gets in their rolls and drives to their
mansion puts their head on their [ __ ]
10 000 thread count whatever cotton
sheet
and goes thank god i fought the good
fight today
that's what the tech world is they're
all
hall monitors in a [ __ ] crumbling
school
and they're telling everybody that's
walking around they can't have any
goddamn
fun now i'm not saying you should be
able to
threaten to kill people and burn down
houses online though i have
uh i'm not saying that but i think that
you should have the freedom to explore
ideas and
uh that's the example that comes to mind
because that's what they feel like they
feel like the
the parental monitor
at the school dance where they're like
well these kids don't know what's going
on
these kids if they were worthy of making
their own decisions
they'd have a billion dollars that's
what that whole monitor looked at those
kids went
if you could decide what you could say
to each other and what you guys could
handle
you'd have a rolls royce outside but yet
out you're broke
so you clearly don't know what the
hell's going on i'll have to come in and
tell you
because i care about you and now we've
kicked you out of the school and now you
get to go live on the street
because i care because god forbid
somebody else heard that little exchange
you had in the hall
and killed themselves because they heard
that so we're protecting that
phantom metaphorical situation that
hasn't happened
and we're gonna destroy your very actual
life to protect from the idea that
someone somewhere might one day
kill themselves because of what you said
so that's where we're at that's where
we're at there's there i can't really
start talking about
i'll be this they will kick me off this
soon probably within a few weeks but
i just want to get a few weeks because
it is fun
but i'm not i would never disclose what
someone said in a private thing and i
want
and i will never in a private uh uh
private i would never disclose what they
say although i think i have on this show
now four times
but not who they are and really not
their exact quotes
i've you know removed those and ands and
ors
because i get it it's a closed circle
i'm i'm probably so off this but
what are you gonna do what am i gonna be
a venture capitalist come on
um yeah it's like i just look at
uh and there are people that don't agree
with these people by the way on there
and there is a movement in tech
that they don't want this and there are
good guys just like there are people in
the cia that's like let's not [ __ ] the
kids
maybe we shouldn't just go into
countries and i don't know overthrow
governments that that country elected
and maybe we shouldn't do that
and then those people of course you know
go away
they disappear but there is a movement
intact for people that want
like more freedom and they they
understand comedy and they like
comedians and they want
fun and as long as you're not really
trying to
hurt somebody and doxing them and
threatening them and
you know putting their information out
there and organizing an online mob to go
kill them or whatever which i can i
didn't do
with the [ __ ] people in the desert
enough
um we know that there's instances where
you know you can't commit crimes online
right you can't
go like let's go kill betty we know that
but there's also this huge gray area
with all that stuff and
there are people from the weinstein crew
i think peter thiel and all those guys
and yes
yes yes whitney webb yes they're
probably cia shows
but you just gotta choose your demons
honey like i love her to death but like
you gotta choose your demons what are we
doing here
you gotta choose your demon it's never
not gonna be a demon
i know all of you like to live in this
world where demons don't run everything
good go terraform and maybe do that on
another planet
but in this world you better choose
the ones you like better choose the ones
you like
that's it you could be a bill gates guy
i was
hey sheldon adelson worked for me he's
like casinos
we're going to kill ya but come to the
casino
bill gates is like we're going to kill
you but he can't even leave home i'm
like at least let's go to the casino
can we go to the casino i don't know
much about sheldon i know he also did
horrible things
don't type out a long youtube car
sheldon adelson actually owned private
prison i know
sheldon adelson you know but it is a
picky demons thing here
so i do think that peter thiel who's
like a gay silicon valley
like unwoke dude right seems to be
maybe maybe the interests align more
with his
clique than the blue haired tech
i don't know i mean it's scary and then
the white woman it's very scary on there
the successful white woman is there a
scarier
uh uh archetype of human being than the
billionaire
white [ __ ] you're gonna go to jail
they're putting you in jail
the billionaire white woman who's like
you know it's just very important to me
that we're really you know
margin you know you know elevating
marginalized voices i want to connect
with young entrepreneurs of color
female entrepreneurs of color and i just
i just really
think it's so important that we create a
space in an environment
that allows everybody to thrive and in
order to do that
i think we have to use every tool at our
disposal you know including putting
guardrails up online and possibly
genocide
thank you is there anyone more
terrifying
than the successful white woman i'm
truly
i mean the aggrieved
successful white woman the woman
with billions of dollars who's gonna fix
it oh god
oh god i mean i listen to this i fall
asleep to this app every night
so i just i just i just every night
i curl up in bed and i just put the
phone on
uh the pillow next to me and
i just fall asleep every night to just
the sound of a white woman who wants me
in jail
because you know what we're really
thinking about is building an
infrastructure and
you know enhancing the user experience
and you know in order to do that of
course what we have to do is you know
you know basically cleanse and you're
like
you start waking up like wait what what
you know we just have to like make sure
that we elevate the right voices and
you're like oh
uh oh and listen i'm sure they're all
lovely people
i'm sure they're all lovely people but
it is
it's not it in my mind it's going to a
bad place but there are people that
don't want it to go
to as bad a place as you think it's
going to go
but see this is the thing because what
people don't realize if you [ __ ] on
people for 40 years
okay in every imaginable way lie to them
you know their wages don't go up they
don't have health care they can't afford
to put their kids through college
their communities are being hollowed out
factories are leaving
everybody's on heroin things are worse
every year
and yet things are somehow more
expensive that's what california's like
things are worse every year
and yet phenomenally more expensive
every year
it's cigarettes we're running a country
that is marlborough lights
every year people die the statistics are
more and more clear
and every year they go how about 17 you
know what
that's california it's a cigarette it's
just you know you shouldn't have it
it's good you like it but every year
they go what about 15. you go i guess
i guess i'll pay i guess i'll give you a
buy cigarettes and lighter and get a
dollar back that makes sense
do that seven times a week but
that's you know where we're at and it's
uh
and and so you can't shoot on people 40
years and expect
there's these little rebellions there
people getting angry
some of them go full queueing on put the
horns on storm the capital
some of them go okay well i'm just going
to go on parlor they go well [ __ ] you
you can't do that
some of them okay well let's make a
little money in the market let's try to
make money let's try to take some money
where's amc right now by the way where
is it amc
stock got to worry about my own position
oh you're up right now tim
how am i up because you bought at 8.98
i'm up
hold the line hold the goddamn line
we're gonna have the ceo of wall street
bets on unfortunately the ceo know what
what is he um so i looked into him his
name's jamie
apparently he was excommunicated from
our wall street bets
apparently a lot of people dm to me that
you were interacting with that account
so i don't know if he is accepted by
that community or if they'd be mad if we
were talking to you i don't know but we
missed it anyway because the whitney
cummings podcast went long
yeah where i sat down with whitney for
two hours we patched we had some issues
we kind of hashed it out
um you know and i love whitney and want
the best for her
i'm you know and i and i care about her
deeply and that's why i'm leaving the
state no i'd love her to death but she's
going to come down and visit we got to
get the [ __ ] out of here man i'm
starting to feel like
i mean we just california feels like the
house after the party you wake up and
there's just cigarettes everywhere and
it smells dank
you know your friend's mother is just
like you want eggs you're like no
get me out of here let's go let's go get
a bacon egg and cheese
cup of coffee and a pack of lucky's
and that is austin to me even though
they probably don't have
i'm a little endless i'm not excited
about austin i loathe austin i abominate
all truly i mean and i and i mean this
with my heart uh
that's not a city for me you know 40
year old failed musicians
scooping ice cream stoned at 3 p.m
dressed like toddlers is never gonna
it's not going to be for me
just isn't sorry i know everyone loves
it
but maybe i'll grow to love it there's
parts of it i like i didn't like this
and i made it work um and new york which
i love
don't get me started on new york so i
don't love anything that i don't hate
you know all my friends i kind of
there's something about them i really
love and then there's something about
them i
don't like those are a lot of the
relationships i have i like
really love them and then i also there's
something about them like i don't like
you know uh and that's
you know and sometimes it's just as
simple as the fact that they refuse to
[ __ ] me and give me all their money
but i still feel that quality to be
objectionable
in some of my friends um
like what i what i like about ben is
that i love ben he's like my best friend
but
also what i don't like about ben is he's
not good at golf and i am really good at
golf
and he's not a good golfer never was
that's what bothers me about him
now obviously that's funny because ben
was a very good girlfriend i don't golf
at all
but the reality is ben knows if i put my
mind to it i could be the greatest
golfer in the world
and maybe i'll do that i'll quit comedy
so i could just be the greatest golfer
of all time
and he has to stand on the sidelines and
just
while i walk up 18 in augusta and the
crowd roars my name
they roar my name and i just walk there
and i hold the club up
and i just have those khakis and that
polo shirt and everybody's just happy
and
you said golfers are boring very boring
i i had a guy come over the other day we
didn't do anything
you know but he was just so boring he
golfs
she's a golfer he's a boring golfer he
just sat outside
and just they they're nothing they're
literally just
they just want to watch that little ball
going to the hall and they just love
jesus
and donald trump and trump yeah they
love jesus and trump
and they just want to watch the ball go
into the hole and i get it because
listen they're you know you got to be
good at something right so
we'll see but so i'm up right now amc
hold the line and we're going head you
got to go in heavy
not now it's up buy the dips [ __ ] these
people
[ __ ] elizabeth warren where's gamestop
oh it's
it's doing okay three twenty doing okay
do i go in the game stop now no
i think you buy a dip i gotta buy the
dip yeah
the unfortunate thing is when it hits
like 400 they halt trading and then it's
like it
that's like illegal it has to be that's
illegal
you know what else is illegal killing uh
john f kennedy
that didn't really stop but it's illegal
they're halting the trading
i mean i just don't get it folks
it's falling now no uh we're going up
right now we're going out going up
ben is now in the stocks he like thinks
he's an investment like a financial
advisor
and he's been trading stocks secretly
for how long without letting me know
like three weeks
yeah and he's not let me know because he
wants to i think he wants to leave the
show
and he wants to create uh an
infrastructure
we have to create an infrastructure and
he wants to
uh make enough money now in the in
capital markets where he just doesn't
have to
do this show anymore because he truly
really hates me
that's the thing about him that none of
you understand is that every day he sits
here and he just
wishes he had the guts to plunge a
kitchen knife into my throat
he's heard me talk more than anyone he
really has think about that
you guys hear me talk an hour a week two
hours a week if you're on the patreon
uh bennett just hears me talk for hours
and hours and at to a point where it's
like
not only i'm sure is it not fun the
grading nature of my voice has to just
it's just like he drives home
there's a little tesla and then he's
probably just like [ __ ] that guy
but you're excited about austin because
you're going to see your family stoked
and a lot of your friends live there
yeah i got family outside dallas it's
gonna be great yeah it's gonna be great
go down there and golf go down there and
retire
ben thinks he's going down to retire
he's gonna work how's nokia
it's been really going down today this
is the end of the day friday right
this is the market ah on friday
we're recording this is going out
saturday
and then we'll we'll see what happens
baby hopefully they can get above board
here
i hope so too i just want to know if i
should just start dumping money into
other things
on the dip is there there's i can buy
after hours right
no uh with td ameritrade i don't know if
you can
interesting yeah [ __ ] robinhood by the
way get
get my twitter up this is something i
found out
this is gonna blow your mind you want
your mind blown
do you want your mind blown what is that
by the way
what oh yeah i tweeted uh elizabeth
warren okay keep going down
okay oh by the way that guy josh brown
cnbc wears the fake business
isn't that nice good for him there he
goes
get go down you're going to lose your
mind here watch this this is a fact
the ceo of robinhood is just lane
maxwell's son
that's real did you know that no that's
just lane maxwell's son
why is that funny well he's russian
right correct
well his name his name's not gonna be
maxwell
that's legit that's legit that's legit
i'm saying it's legit because i care
about you
you see that i care about you so much
i almost want to start crying that's why
i'm sharing this information with you
because i care about you so much
that i want you to believe this
they do look alike that's how believable
it is i mean
it's so believable because they do look
alike now it's probably not the it's
probably not the case
and it kind of looks like jeffrey and
just lane like
how to cross do you think that just lane
is trading in prison
do you think he's on the phone with a
broker i want to buy a game stop
i feel so sad here i'm in chair i want
to buy amc i love the movies
i want to get in heavy to gamestop and
nokia
listen i want to go against the rich too
my whole life i've been serving the rich
i want to go against i want to get a
part of a populist revolution
i want about douchecoin tell everyone
about dogecoin ben
so dogecoin's an altcoin um it's a risky
investment because it's not like real
didn't it go up 800 percent
it did yeah i sold early i shouldn't
have but elon musk tweeted about bitcoin
today and it went up yeah and he put it
in his bio
get in the game folks elon's leading the
charge on this whole thing
he really is well because you know
the one thing about elon musk is that
he's poor and he understands the
struggles of poor people
and that's why i'm kidding no he's kind
of a populist now right
yeah him and chamoth uh chamath uh
what's this guy yeah yeah this guy
they're they're kind of leading the
charge with the bitcoin stuff
yeah listen this facebook and robinhood
app are the same they both trick you
into thinking you were the customer but
in fact
you are the product and your data is the
asset
these assets are then sold to their true
customers who pay the money and always
at your expense not being traded
which i think is like citadel owns all
the data now citadel is like
they own all the data from robinhood so
you're trading on robinhood and
citadel's going what are they buying
how are they buying it you know
so that is the real asset to real
commodity and that's interesting that's
why robinhood is
owned really truly by these big money
players the robin hood is a billionaire
too but like the institutions are who he
has that's where his loyalty is it is
not to his customers
it is to the people that own that app
and get his the information the data
that he
sells them right and then when you
understand that
you understand how this whole thing
works and if you have trouble
understanding you just got to go up the
line
until somebody's in the woods with a
goat mask because that's really the way
it is
so you just got you go but i don't
understand it doesn't make sense and
then it's like oh
here's a photo of you with jeffrey
epstein's birthday what do you think
about this you go
well i'm concerned about the market
instability
and i'm concerned about so up the line
they just go right into blackmail if
they need to just go in a hardcore
blackmail
but you don't even have to do that
anymore because people are just so
terrified of being ruined financially
being on the road because this this will
die down right because all these hedge
fund guys
the way they talk to they go listen this
is going to end this will end
and when it does you ju it's like
your kid and the bully picks on you
but your older brother's there that day
and then the bully is like hey man one
day we're gonna catch you without him
so at the end of the day it's like this
[ __ ] knows he's like hey man
it's gonna end one day you're not gonna
be the folk hero reddit
if that's which you know he didn't
choose that route but like if you go
that route
okay but just realize that one day
we're gonna catch you without your boys
we're gonna catch you without your
avatars
and we're gonna get yeah and that's
that's probably the way
it happens i imagine that's the way it
happens that guy's
threatened he's threatened they bring
him in a room and a guy comes in a room
uh in a goat mask with a cloak and goes
there's two ways we can do this you can
shut down training on these particular
securities
or we can literally at our next seance
roast you on a barbecue spit
in the woods and this guy goes okay
i don't see he's rushing he knows how it
is he knows what they do
they poison you he knows he's a russian
they get it they know people have long
memories over there
lucy nicotine companies founded by
caltech scientists and former smokers
looking for a better and cleaner
nicotine alternative they've got a gum
that comes in
a couple of really cool flavors three of
them winter green cinnamon pomegranate
they also have a lozenge with four
milligrams of nicotine and a cherry ice
flavor
they actually taste great it's
convenient and discreet products can be
enjoyed anywhere on flights at work on
the go or even the gym
you don't have to be like this more on
vaping all the time you don't have to be
me have an occasional mar be light
you can get out there it's 20 20 get rid
of your cigarettes unplug your vape
throw out your dip get some lucy
nicotine gum or lozenges
this is the real deal a subscription
lucy comes directly to your door each
month
it's so simple it's a great way to
support the show and it'll get you off
nicotine
forever tim dillinger listeners go to
lucy.co
promo code tim lucy.co promo code tim
and get 20
all full products including gum and
losses that's lucy.co
promo code tim at checkout also i have
to give this disclaimer
warning this product contains nicotine
derived from tobacco nicotine
is an addictive chemical lucy.co
be sure to use the promo code t-i-m you
owe it to yourself to make 2021
your year it's time to change things up
start with some self-care
start with hawthorne hawthorne is a
premium tailored personal care brand
that's make it easier for guys
to feel and smell your best okay you
take a little quiz they're like what's
your favorite drink
how do you like to spend the night out
do you smoke what are you doing
the products i got are amazing
i got skin care products i got products
that make me smell
good if you want to upgrade your
self-care routine hawthorne is a fun and
convenient way to get super
high quality products tailored
specifically for your needs aftershave
things like that creams
hawthorne even takes the risk out of it
by giving you free shipping on your
order and returns
and if you don't like your products
they'll even retailer them for you based
on your feedback do what i did
take hawathorn's quiz today and get
started on your personalized self-care
routine
by going to hawthorne.co use promo code
tim get 10 off your first purchase
hawthorne.co promo code tim hawthorne.co
promo code t i am
but get on clubhouse because it is a lot
of fun and i hope i get to stay on it
because i don't think i've disclosed too
much this
is just what it is these are my best
friends now on clubhouse they're
children they're venture capitalists
they all started hedge funds at seven
they're all young these people are i'm
36 i'm like elderly
now obviously there's people in
clubhouse that are older
and you know it's just like anything
else there's like tech people that like
haven't made it
and there's a term for them called
entrepreneurs
entrepreneurs like one of them was like
yeah anyone could go on instagram but
like if you can't come on clubhouse and
tell me for 20 minutes about your thing
you're a entrepreneur wow
so there are those there are people on
clubhouse by the way that are like
just you could tell they're like they're
like oh hey
cliff you know long time no see
you know you know it's like oh boy
every now and then they get a yahoo in
there who's like is there a microchip in
the vaccine and they're like that's
completely unfounded
while they're sitting there putting it
right there
but uh it is a lot of fun we and ben are
on it all the time we plan to be on it
even more we have fake sometimes i do
fake financial seminars
on there i'm doing a comedy show on
their sunday i'm doing
10 minutes of comedy i don't know how
that's gonna work not
really excited about that but you know
we'll see what happens i might get a
call
after this drops saturday night they go
yeah man that got cancelled
nobody listen it is no secret
that there's a lot of people out there
that have very different ideas of how
your life should be run and when you
hear them talk about it
it is interesting it's fascinating i can
listen to it for hours
it's endlessly fascinating to hear the
way these people's minds work because
they're always in the shadows we always
talk about them the tech titans the
oligarchs the technocracy
and then you actually hear the and it's
not a conspiracy
and i'm sure that the finance [ __ ] is
not really a conspiracy either
it's just these communities in these
echo chambers they can exist on 4chan
about pelosi eating kids or they can
exist in silicon valley there's these
echo chambers
and you just hear the way these people
formulate their thoughts and ideas about
the world
and you understand how everything works
and also how hopeless everything kind of
is
because you go oh if it was this top
down conspiracy it's like you might be
able to unravel it
but it's like no it's just this
consensus being created
all the time with all this social
pressure and there's all these people
that are highly gifted very intelligent
very driven very motivated
very rich but they also want to really
be good people
and they don't know how to be and they
don't realize
they don't know how because they've
spent their entire lives really being
brutally committed to themselves and
that's how you make that kind of money
you are very much into you
i didn't get to be a funny comedian by
spending 10 years
feeding the poor i feed them now
they're my friends but most of the time
i was focused on my craft
being funny doing comedy making sketches
podcasting
so these people who've spent their
lives thinking about number one
are now in this position where they've
been thrust into the public spotlight
and i'm sure they now want to help and
how do you help well i can't give you my
money
i can't give you all my money
so we gotta admit it's kind of you got
it gotta be a little
nicer you gotta be nice
you like guys you're like being very
hurtful right now
and you like have to consider people's
emotional state
and their mental health and you can't
really say anything
and that's yeah
okay now go on this
app and that's where you can see your
family
that's when you're allowed to like see
our family
and if you're giving your children
advice we don't like we're just going to
shut it off
you'll be the platform from your family
if you keep it up
you know imagine that just the kids at
the like the kids sitting at the dinner
table looking at their father they're
like dad you've been de-platformed
you said i should lose weight and that's
like you should kids like
dad you're de-platformed
that was hurtful but when you hear these
people speak it really you get this idea
of like oh that so that's where the
cognitive dissonance comes from
they're they're entrepreneurs highly
successful
uh people then they then have to be
people who are altruistic
and they have to have a social
conscience and then they go
okay what's the most important thing
ending racism
there it is ending misogyny
ending cruelty we're going to end
cruelty
we'll do that and then maybe
somewhere in there if possible
you'll maybe get a knee operation that
you need so you don't have to
limp around but before you get that knee
operation
we're going to make sure none of those
kids call you stumpy or something
that's more important it's actually more
important for us that you're not made
fun of for your condition
than medicating you for that condition
that's more important for us
yeah you got cancer but
and you shaved your head but nobody
called you baldy
right been like no everyone's been very
nice i'm dying
but everyone's been lovely they've been
absolutely lovely
and that's where we're at and that's
what's a little terrifying to me
that's what's terrifying to me we've
created adam curtis hybrid normalization
a fake world this fake world of uh
technology where the real world and
every now and then it bleeds into the
real world
some guy with horns runs into the
capital uh somebody burns your business
down
uh because the cop shot a guy uh there's
a massive
[ __ ] terrorist attack because people
overseas or here
were able to connect with each other uh
whatever the case may be
but for the most part it's this fake
world that we've created
that allows us to feel like we're really
good people
and that we're doing the right thing but
all of the problems in our
real lives get worse every day
all of your problems get worse and what
does it force you to do
just log on just come in here
no one will be mean to you no one will
say the wrong thing
you want a job come on in you want to be
heard
say what we want you to say that's all
and you don't go outside can't go
outside it's dangerous
it's for your own good you're making
money the stock market so that that's
what you're dealing with i wish you were
only dealing with one
group of nefarious elites you're
actually dealing with
many different cartels of people all
who want you dad
it's a little depressing but but it is
fun it's a fun app wish i'd invested in
it
it's a fun app if the peasants could
hear the king they would
if you had spent all the day pulling the
turnips out of the ground
and then the lord was driving but you
know and the lord was coming buying his
horse
and he's like you get it more and you're
like
you're just dirty and drunk and then
when you went to the tavern
if there was a way for you to hear what
the king
planned to do to you tomorrow
you would listen you'd listen
and you'd like some of them even though
they were killing you
even though they were destroying you
you'd like them
you know you would sit there at the
tavern you get a little drunk
and then you know the queen would go you
know we must focus
right now on getting more out of them
we got to get more work out of them and
somebody in the town be like
you know she's got a lot of class
doesn't she she's got a lot of class
uh she's very well spoken she's very
good speaker
and you'd be like right but she's saying
that we should be whipped more
wrought wrong it's not good is it but
that's what has come impressed i'm
impressed on the club i'm impressed
by um their ability
to articulate the uh shackles i will be
forced to live in for probably the rest
of my days on earth
they're very clear they're very good at
it
so i'm like kind of impressed i'm like
this isn't this is impressive
but it is it is scary but
we're not an investment advice show but
hold the line hold the line
buy the stocks hold their feet to the
fire
try to get an invite to clubhouse not
for me and keep your mouth shut in there
talk if you're
asked to talk but listen listen to
the future
and maybe i'm wrong i'd love to be wrong
i hope i'm wrong
i don't think so but you know because
you know i learned the
pandemics are just coming now they're
just coming
it's the new strains there's 19 strains
and
i'm not saying they're not out there but
it's like it's just
china by the way if you look at china
they're just like
they're in a club like
you know we're driving around our cars
we're like is can can you
throw me a burrito through a window
and china's just partying so i mean
[Music]
at the end of the day folks we're
excited this might be our last episode
of california we don't know we're
looking to get out of
get out of here kind of asap um you know
the new producer on the show lee syat
will be taking over next week
some that's how dumb people are somebody
messaged me like is ben
really leaving
remember the time like we were nice to
each other for one moment and they were
like are you guys
are you leaving the show
but we're going to be down and we're
going to be down to texas i think it'll
be a good change
here and here's something to think about
wherever you're quarantined you're going
to want to leave
if you can wherever you were in a
quarantine you just kind of want to get
out of there you're going to want
something
new you're not you're just going to want
to go somewhere new
you know and back that that's when i
thought the quarantine was ending which
it's going to be rolling quarantines
rolling pandemics new apps more fun
here's zoom it's gonna be a lot more fun
just get on the app it's okay just get
on the app shut your mouth
get on the app get the vaccinate chili's
go from chili's right to your home don't
stop and see a friend we consider that
uh any uh gathering of three or more
people we can
consider domestic terror so no
gatherings no large gatherings back to
the house
back on the app where you'll be
monitored everything
you say and do will be listened to your
data will all be sold to companies that
market uh to you
uh you know uh cookie dough popsicles or
whatever you're gonna get
and then you just sit in your house and
if you don't like it if you don't like
it
you can just we can just get rid of you
and then we don't know what happens
i don't know you could go to the woods
and uh you know do whatever you want
but this is the reality this is the
future
and it's gonna come with some cool [ __ ]
too it'll have some fun stuff
you know you know chelsea handler will
you know narrate a documentary about
nelson mandela
uh you know elliott page will remind you
that the uh you don't need food anymore
the green powder that's delivered to
your house is sufficient
and you'll be you'll be like ellie it's
brian i don't know why i always do
british for that but it's
fun but you'll just go elliot elliot's
really brave and then you'll eat the
green powder you'll put water in it
it'll become like a souffle
that's what i think we'll eat in the
future it'll become like a just like as
interesting like souffle type of uh
thing with protein and everything and
you'll just eat that and then the
holidays you'll get food
the holidays they'll be they'll be like
food for you you can have like food
you'll be like i remember
but then you'll get all bloated and
you'll be like i remember this is not
even
god remember we ate this every day that
was gross
so like you'll you'll get to eat like
one thanksgiving
a year and then you'll feel like [ __ ]
and then you'll just look fo
you'll actually look forward to like the
green souffle
that you just need water for where you
just eat it every day
and then they'll be like and they'll be
different kinds of souffle be like all
different flavors
so it'll be like 30 flavors and then p
and if you complain about that people
get mad at you
they'll be like there's 30 [ __ ]
flavors
they're like dude i used to be able to
go to the grocery store and cook what i
wanted to
be like dude everyone died from that you
go not really
they go yeah they did that's why we eat
the purple souffle
to honor elliot page you know what
the you'll they'll have the gay souffle
with a little different color it's it's
the bravery of elliott you're just like
i kind of sometimes i want a steak and
they go
elliott they'll just start screaming at
you
everyone will be non-binary in hollywood
within five years every
one will be non-bi watch as soon as your
career dips a little like it'll dip a
little bit
you go right back up like a stock it's
like a stock like uh older older not
great not the best looking non-binary
back back back back back it's just gonna
be like a stock
buy on the dips you should have bought
elliott paige on the dip
because she's back they're back sorry
[ __ ] i'm off now they're back
by elliot on the dip
because they are coming back and hold
the line
on elliott hold the [ __ ] line
but i'm i'm happy people made some money
i hope they continue to make money the
forces
that are united against us here
are inconceivably powerful
incredibly dedicated very connected
and every day while you are sleeping
they are marshaling their considerable
amount of
power all of their resources
their legal team their marketing
department
their brand ambassadors their social
media influencers
they're getting them all together and
they're going to put together a war
chest
of [ __ ] just the it's just going to
blind you you're going to just be
blinded you're not even going to be
you're going to barely be able to
function every day
with the incessant you are going to be
beat you're going to be beaten down
where you love that suit when they
deliver that purple souffle
to your house via drone no contact
and you eat the purple souffle and
you're able to go and
talk to your friends for 20 minutes uh
on an
app uh uh and then if if if somebody
says something like
you know you know what doesn't make
sense to me it'll just
they're off they'll be like your room
doesn't seem positive shall i remove the
disrupter
shall i remove the negative person and
you know what you go kind of yeah
you'll go yeah you kind of want them
gone
you know so just know that guys like me
are gonna seem crazier and crazier and
crazier every year
um and that's why we'll just all have to
go with the program
i'm just we're we're just gonna we're
gonna have to kind of go along with the
program
like i will have to transition to a
woman to keep doing the show truly
i will have to transition to a woman to
just keep doing this show
i'll have to come out here and and i'll
have to talk like this like an alexa
everyone on clubhouse is basically alexa
they're just
alexa and they go we're really looking
for
is different ways to use streaming to
enhance the user experience
we're very excited about that we're very
excited
i'm really looking to partner with young
entrepreneurs young women of color
and really trying to elevate
marginalized voices to create a space
where people are treated fairly and
respected because all over the world
what we've realized here in silicon
valley what we've realized
is all over the world people have the
exact
same needs and that is everybody
everywhere no matter gender identity or
race
truly wants to be forever and always
a slave and we're gonna do that for them